hey welcome back
this summer's protests for black lives
aren't just happening in the streets
they're also happening on the playing
field and on the court
it used to be the exception for an
athlete to take a stand on civil rights
but turn on a game recently and it's
like church
everybody's kneeling they're doing it in
basketball baseball
football even hockey instead of agreeing
to shut up and dribble
players are using their platforms to
speak up for justice
so here to help me figure out where all
this is going and how it's changing
professional sports is u.s women's
soccer team co-captain and two-time
fifa world cup champion megan rupino
welcome megan thank you for having me
this is so exciting
i appreciate it i know how busy you are
maybe but what i was thinking about you
you were like one of the first uh
white athletes to publicly kneel in
solidarity with colin kaepernick how did
that decision come about
i mean pretty quickly to be honest um
you know we had just come through this
just horrific summer um you know i had
seen what the wnba players were doing a
little bit earlier in the summer
and you know starting to read more i
mean i obviously know about racism but
just reading more about it yeah
generally about racism
there's this thing called racism i think
right yeah have you heard it
but yeah just kind of like you know
educating myself more and then obviously
when when colin kneel you couldn't not
see it it was it was everywhere
immediately i was just like oh okay this
is something that
that i can do that i can help i have you
know not a platform like
collins or like the nfls but i have some
sort of
platform and it just kind of came easily
to me and i was just like i'm going to
do this um
not really not knowing what the backlash
was gonna be
but but that's what makes these protests
courageous in that type of thing there's
usually a price to be paid you know but
that's why people admire people who
speak out like colin did you get a lot
of blow back from
fans or how about teammates like how did
they react to this
uh yeah fans were very very mad
wow wait is that where this came from
doing this is like
[ __ ] you guys yeah
that became the evolution yes exactly
exactly
certainly this summer um you know
overall i think my teammates
were supportive and also like
what is going on obviously the narrative
at the time was it's anti-american it's
anti-military it's
everything other than what it actually
was about um
but i felt support from them the
national team was a little different
they didn't um
they didn't quite support me really in
anything
no no definitely not definitely not
which they've
basically since apologized for and they
actually made a rule
in the subsequent months after um
banning players from kneeling which
they've now retracted in the wake of
george floyd and all the black lives
matter protests this summer yeah it's
funny how
fast opinions change in this you know
especially from some of those
uh corporate levels and everything and
you're currently in the wnba bubble
which is kind of cool
you know they're just starting their
their playoffs i feel like they were
fierce the way they came out
of the blocks just you know showing
solidarity
and the way they platformed it and
everything i thought was great
it's been exceptional to have an up
close look at
all these players that yeah you know my
girlfriend sue obviously is a is a
player
and so just seeing how gracefully
they have handled all of this because so
many of these women i think that the
league is 80
black you know as you know i feel like
black women are at the intersection of
all of this and they were like
we've been here we've been doing this
work exactly people are just finally
painting people are catching up now
yeah they're handling it all with such
grace and you know the work
you know being done behind the scenes
honestly that people aren't even seeing
is just
exceptional right uh i have to okay
since i'm a comedian i'm naturally
contrary right
and part of me with the sports world
because i love sports i'm a big laker
fan of course
but i'm afraid i don't like it to get
too performative
as opposed to productive like i
appreciate i'm like good for you players
black lives matter on the court on your
jerseys you know but i get concerned
with too much sloganeering it seems like
there's a corporate thing
that kind of takes over and sometimes
people think sloganeering
is the same as activism but it really
isn't like things still have to get done
it's a very fine line i think
um there needs to be the long
arduous work of activism and organizing
that isn't
initially gratifying and so i think it
can be
you know sort of dizzying for people in
a way who are new to it but
you do need the sort of outward show of
support the black lives
matter on the court is amazing the names
on the back of the shirt for the wnba is
incredible
but then it's like we need committed
concerted effort
to solving some of these problems yeah
because you don't want people to go
like i don't want to see somebody
dunking lebron and go wait who was that
say her name no say your name i just
want to know who
it is it's like but i get it guys
you're you want to enrage thank you i
get that but but help a brother out of
here you know
you can't have too many things exactly
exactly that's all i'm saying
that's all i'm saying just focus me i'm
like a labrador just trying to figure
out what's going on you know
uh let me ask you this do players and
athletes feel like there's a need
to have policy prescriptions i think
athletes do
feel kind of in this tough spot where
they have this big platform and they
want to use it
and then of course the detractors come
in with like oh you don't have a full
fudge policy that's already been put
into place and like
it's like what are you talking about i'm
not the mayor i'm the captain of the
team
not the mayor i bounce the ball i don't
know what we're talking about
and and it's like you can never do
enough i mean i think lebron is a
perfect example he's
he literally does have one that's crazy
you know a voting organization
and a school you know all of this stuff
you can almost never do
enough and so you're always going to be
a little left short but i would just
encourage people don't
don't focus too much on the detractor
they'll always be well what about this
what about this what about this and it's
like well what are you doing
other than detracting from what i'm
doing i feel like
athletes using their voice and using
that platform is enough
yeah how do you see the lgbtq community
and allyship with the black lives
matter movement because we're seeing
some interesting ally ships going on
here too which i think really helps a
lot of these causes as well
yeah absolutely um i think something
that's amazing about the black lives
matter movement first of all it's
started by
um black women queer black women and i
think that
you know especially now you're seeing so
many of the leaders
being at these intersectional points of
being black and queer
and it's like if those people are
leading
they're not leaving a lot of people
behind we've seen this time and again i
mean we just
you know celebrated the the women's
right to vote and it's like
well did women really get the right to
vote
not oh people did oh women we left a lot
behind didn't we
and so that it's it's vital it's like a
vital part of
making progress and i just feel like
sometimes we think we're making progress
but if some of those marginalized people
within our
communities are still left behind what
kind of progress is that really
i think that you're absolutely right
thank you so much megan for joining me
my first episode here
on wilmore and be safe in that in that
wnba bubble
i will thank you for having me on
you